[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
me
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i noticed my mic was farther away so
i'll push my mic closer
all right what's going on guys you
should be able to hear us pretty good
right now
uh you know definitely tell me in the
chat because i know you guys will if we
bugging i need to know man i need to
know i'll check that now as we're
talking
hopefully this ain't my prediction yeah
cog just sent me a message showing me
that there might be copyrighted content
yeah i i know that car
uh that i know this is gonna get claimed
off to start uh because uh i feel like
they do that on par not not like sony
but i feel like like companies do that
on purpose so they can claim it and get
the uh the ad revenue on some of these
videos man because it'd be too
it'd be too hard to go around
sometimes
yeah i'm just muted i'm a muted when it
comes up yeah well that and also like
like that's what i was going to say you
can box it put it to the side because i
see what other dudes really yes it is
it's different things that you could do
that could take that can block that um
yeah no it's the music that gets you
it's the music that gets you well
because the algorithm hears the music
but also they also have video checkers
too because some dudes like nintendo
bang you for putting up video of their
games
so what nintendo doesn't do it no more
actually nintendo is yeah they're still
open with it yeah they're pretty they're
switching successful they fooled people
well but even before that though cause
that that was a whole thing the way
people like was doing you uh play let's
plays on youtube and all that yeah
nintendo was cracking down everybody
stopped and then the you know the the
roar was loud enough the way they was
like all right okay not that but free
promo man yeah see but see that's what
they realize uh we're playing we're
paying this uh our um marketing team
where these dudes is free freely
marketing stuff yup we do it every day
listen i'm guilty of doing it when i'm
yelling out here game pass and all that
other stuff right there and i already
told dudes i've been bought and sold
you know mr aaron greenberg greeny lord
green he definitely didn't bless the kid
and
and money rumble definitely hit the kid
up while i was out there so
um at no point in time do i lie and tell
somebody oh no no no listen if you had a
ton of free services at some point in
time you're gonna sit there and look
back and be like yo now this is a hell
of a deal but at the same time i paid
for my sons
right so i didn't really know he get the
you know full uh xbox ultimate uh game
pass ultimate so he don't even got a pc
but um
but when he well he has a laptop for
school but he doesn't have a pc to to
primarily game on because i don't trust
the pc community at all especially with
my infant you know infant but he's mine
no you guys should that's your baby
yeah so
um i i still you know give that money
back and that money goes rolls back in
and i buy my dlc and all that other
stuff i got to justify my purchases i
don't care about nothing someone said
uh they can hear us by the way but
someone said the one dislike his heart
like look man
heart actually be
look i know
christopher hart is that playstation
but he he he in that chat every week
every week like there's something
like there's some of you that that show
up when you can but christopher hart in
that chat every week i know for a fact
that ain't his dislikes
chris don't put no dislikes chris is
having fun chris i finally do
online gonna sit there and bother me
right
and i'm gonna leave this controller down
here because i i don't need it no
multiplayer games
got one upstairs and when it died then i
could come downstairs to get this guy oh
because you can't change the battery oh
oh oh
hold on
[Laughter]
so uh quick question real quick what's
your guys's expectations let's give the
chat a little bit of conversation what
is your expectation for this king
oh jim dance moves ryan then got blood
born on the pc
oh oh no i don't think they announced
that here
i think y'all i don't know
like on the real they might like to be a
hundred they might like i expect final
fantasy 16 here i expect maybe even
another like announcement for final
fantasy vii remake i don't know if it
would be like a part two or something
like that
um i doubt it but maybe they'll they'll
have like another expansion or something
i don't know exactly how that how that
doing i didn't expect a youthy thing so
i can't really say i wouldn't expect
something else you know what i'm saying
so 20 minutes of uh 20 minutes and 10 of
what will be indies and three will be vr
oh no then okay there's not gonna be
that many stuff man
oh man because you know i think they'll
probably show grand theft auto because
that's getting rid of their driving but
they show grand theft auto i'm into the
stream
don't do that they'll probably show part
three since part three is uh exclusive
to ps now
well
no i said you're cut off of my in a
little bit let me fix that
there we go
you weren't really cut off but it was
bothering me so it it it needed to be
addressed
oh you're fine i'm gonna dead one of
these okay
kill i'm looking at the twitch stream is
that what you're looking at
no i'm looking at the youtube
okay so i just want to be honest at the
same time y'all that's all
all right youtube
jump over there playstation
watch the the show's gonna
all right first off i'm gonna turn this
up just a little bit guys tell me how
it's like the the difference in the
sound well what yeah why on youtube
on youtube okay like the attic link the
can you link the
we got chat in here yes
this is where we're watching today this
is where we're washing it at guys
i'm turning this up
is it
[Applause]
what is this
i have no idea this is what you get
how does it how does the audio sound
guys
[Applause]
yo this is some crazy looking stuff
y'all said don't want a multiplayer well
here we go
[Music]
it's a single player multiplayer
[Music]
oh
reminds me of um
what's that game um
that game
the card game on xbox
the card game
yeah the one that they remade
i don't know i didn't even know if we
made the card game in that class
this looked like destruction
so this legit looks like something
composting studios really did
and that's not that's not necessarily a
bad thing
come spring 2022 that's what was your
first look at death verse let it die
coming to ps4 and ps5
war sucks
um just doesn't have anything to do with
politics or race or imperialism
out there we look to each other and to
our
thick arms
you done
is arms
what are we the
but you know playstation guy's gonna see
that cool little cat in the car
i want to reach more people but i don't
think i trust people who use hashtags
you're the best at this you're the best
i'm proud of you i'm proud of you i just
do things
carter what you're working on just a
little audio filter i cooked up for
debug here can debug make me sound like
a demon sound like a demon okay okay uh
give me one more one give me one more
run through and we'll take a proper
break okay hi okay hi
we are off we are off
i probably picked up from my headset
sorry okay you get diamonds
the stream
that's five episodes five episodes
and playstation 4 in 2022 the future the
future the music
we are pause man
i'm done with that
we love you
okay bye
the future
horses shares a big update coming to
budget oh bug snacks the remix
ah let's get it
who acts with his bug snacks
i got the mugs next
someone in the chat says
that's right
we need to form an expedition
we need to form an expedition
is the balance a little bit better guys
where you can hear us both
[Music]
oh
the world is a magnificent girl it's not
all buddies
and hens so keep checking your mail do
some redecorating and before you know it
they thought they was gonna come up with
what's that uh um
that game from the nintendo that you
guys like we stopped
animal crossing
mixed with a pokemon
they got it watch out right now there's
a whole cake coming out the ground
the isles of bug smacks they took it
from the block and put it right now in
the caribbean
ryan knows exactly what the place engine
fans want a little bit more bug snacks
five nights at freddy's fans
right here you guys right
[Music]
down the tubes now
oh boy ladies and gentlemen thank you
for visiting
the show
for the halloween theme
i'm really starting to think king uh we
could we could have stayed asleep for
this
i was actually up playing that hard game
um
oh boy
okay
because that might be the vibe with the
stream today
i don't know if i'll stream today
because we i don't know it depends how
well this turns out let me tell you
something
oh look at that until then
yo i'm gonna tell you right now though
if you've ever played the five nights at
freddy's game
um
this stuff is real creepy and fun
it's creepy
like in a cartoon way
people keep telling me to stream it yeah
you're like i said it was a popular
streaming game i don't like
i'm scared type stuff but that's that's
just me that's what it excels at though
yeah i know yeah it's just my thing i
watch other people play it
i can't watch people
that talks at the beginning awesome
night
would you like to take a short survey
about your experience oh 12
16 in a challenging action rpg coming
soon
that's my birthday
oh really oh no 17th birthday oh death
store
they catch it up man they catching up
wow
wow man
they'll get a chance to play it look at
y'all
it looks smaller though
i'm not gonna lie so i did just i signed
up for game pass
to blood playing with the homeless
weekend oh yo hit me up hit me up oh
sure i got you guys playing with cat
daddy fast stacks boys
getting it in me and him my boy mason
i'm gonna tell you right now
game is fun it's different than left for
dead but it's fun okay i know the same
people made the first one but that's
right there definitely i might you know
i might buy this though i might just
copy that on this thing i just say wait
wait for game pass it was already shown
uh sir just sit back nine opponents
maximus really spent the gasps
you support when you play it's called
engagement you got different metrics
buddy don't fall into that old stuff
dude i gotta support death
for all this stuff i've never i've never
wanted my brother interrupt me more my
whole life at least i'd have
entertainment
this does look like a diddy kong racing
type of thing
you see what the thing is
that's the problem with dude they don't
know why mario kart was so successful
why sonic racing team racing was good on
stuff like that it was characters you
cared about
that playstation hadn't done that yet
because pause putting like nathan drake
and just like different they put him in
a fighting game and won't put him in the
car racing game like you need something
to that's going to like rival a mario
kart i think they can do i think they
can do it
we got 330 people in there hit that like
button man let's get that like button up
what's going on peeps
hit that like button up man they don't
they don't like to take risks be honest
if it gets over 200 king will play this
no you won't that's a lie
i am not on patreon for that
i might hit i might hit that bait up and
drag cause i like them caught races man
i got to see
shadow
[Music]
here we go man
[Applause]
all right
you've never been so disgusted to see
that
i have always been oh
the the the king of fighters okay
the crowd goes crazy
hey we got we gotta uh put some respect
i don't care if there's no play we
[Music]
look look you guys
jamaican ryan only comes out for certain
events okay
yeah
is it an everyday thing man what's the
worldwide mr world why don't we show up
worldwide
oh this looks good
hi everyone i'm niels also known as
bitter bird oh god we're gonna listen to
them talk about it turn that up today
excited to share it first
[Music]
featuring a dangerous cocktail of
difficulties
possibilities
that was a good one
when the round begins you'll be assigned
a secret role of either a resident or a
personnel
so this is me i played as a resident in
this game and my goal was to reach kane
at the heart of the israelites and i got
to play support so this is like
[Music]
the most important question is
who can you trust yeah exactly and i
thought you and i are working together
i
this is a good time
let me see if it's
good luck everyone and remember be
careful who you trust because in first
class
longer than friendships
work together to avoid disaster when
first class arrives on ps4 and ps5 next
month now station plus members will be
able to download the ps4 and ps5
versions at no extra cost starting
november 2nd i don't know how the hell
i'm supposed to listen to it no no can
you turn yourself up i'll keep my mute
square enix here we go guys
you should not be able to hear with that
you know what i got my other sms
federation bring them down
weapons it's not a big deal
it's not bad bad
abandon ship all crew members get to an
escape
and apparently
i can't hear it really really bad
why the hell does he have the bon jovi
cut though
well you know it doesn't matter how loud
i turn that up because it's it's zoom
that's making the uh the echo
what is this
take that back
all right
get me familiar
what is square enix doing man this is a
nintendo switch
now can you know it's the playstation
[Music]
base
what's funny is like
square like if this is supposed to be a
multiplayer like an mmo you already got
the most popular mmo in existence right
now
yeah but they're trying to make
[Music]
[Music]
none of the star oceans on the
playstation please go refresh yourself
there's some of the best rpgs before we
wrap up let's get an update on eagerly
awaited
it's almost over
got him
they said before we wrap up yes sir what
what are they updating us on
nothing thanks for playing
yourself
[Laughter]
everybody got the quarter in the middle
now stick it in the slot it's awesome
[Music]
[Laughter]
i think this is this is that game that i
like that i saw all on board
next stop is the bushes
[Music]
[Music]
first stop is overheating bills
second stop just fast ssds no no too
much ssd if you ain't got a heat sink
time to blow
that's why they got the wind turbine in
your controller
i can't think of the name of the game
but this was this was like one of the
indies that i didn't like
you could be in that chat watch it but
you ain't in here
so this is a murder mystery
you got no power in that chat
[Laughter]
this is
i i know that's not it though this this
can't be yet
like
15 minutes right there been that long
this is it it's over
yo they roasting to join the playstation
chat
looking mansion to fulfill his
simple touch
all right here we go he's greeted by
notice
no notice the the plan for moving to the
wind did you notice that
did you notice
vincent yeah
looks like it's kept in the mansion
i do like the off staff
oh he found the question from games
this is what they supposed to be lit
[Music]
i feel like i saw all that xbox heat and
uh worldwide said
give me anything this game listen listen
this game came out with the ps5
when they first came in
tell me the way those things were moving
didn't look crazy
hey but you know what though i heard
this game supposed to be like 120 120
frames a second i think it's at 1080p
but they said it's supposed to be like
one of the first games
i'd rather play death stranding caught
in a
and imagine what he has to do oh boy
inside yeah yeah yeah shout out to you
chris let's try to push behind the chat
hopefully this thing is scary it's like
you know like
i hate
[Music]
no final fantasy
that's our show
that's wild
i got him
we gonna have to talk about this hey
people
and all y'all dudes
thinking
in your soul
that you always go get yourself wow
nothing for the
holidays yeah hey
hey for the record um if y'all think
that we just quote unquote xbox platform
quote-unquote it's not it i'm looking at
the actual playstation chat and they're
going off in that joint right now dawg
ll bruh
it's a lot harder there's a lot going on
in that chat right now
feel the hectic feeling
you can tell me all that on my xbox what
that's wild i didn't know
that that was going to happen the way
that they had because i figured you know
that was going to show god a wall yeah
god of war
but that's that to me is disgusting no
that's right
waste of my time like
i couldn't stay to sleep
i was sleeping real good
and i heard my alarm clock go off and i
first thing i said i owe iop show and i
look man we still gave you a show but
they didn't give me a show they gave me
a show that's wow
a real ish show
you know
you know i don't like to see nobody we
got a two dollar super traffic donatoku
that xbox game showcase looking a lot
better now oh it definitely is i'd
rather watch it inside xbox i'm gonna be
real with you like
yeah i don't wanna hear nothing it's
like it's like going to a buffet and all
they got is lunchables
i mean so does the collective community
take a l on this because we were
straight
i'm not taking no hell with that get out
of here
look we just we just ha we go off what
they do so like that's that's wow oh
look at kofi says state of ass
yo that joint it is crazy though that i
wouldn't expect cause like a few of the
it'd be like hit and miss with with the
whole state of play right
neal said did i really stop watching you
season three for this thing to
oh play is the state of no play for the
rest of the year
fantasy looked different when it was
that beginning
hey what up uh i shot up the kids moving
to chat he said it's trash uh you got
live smooth
hey listen i would have rather them show
grand theft auto like the new joint
that's coming out on the left yeah but
it's coming out on game pass first so
they won't promote that you understand
like they're not gonna
they can promote part three because part
three is going to ps now
after this
we have to start giving state to play
that same energy we give inside xboxes i
never stopped for sure like this this is
ridiculous so we got five dollars super
chat from everborn saga shout out to
everborn beat game they showed with the
best game they showed was death's door
you might not be lying know what the
game that was already on xbox
oh man
uh then we got a five dollar super chat
from mtech 10th
saving the big stuff for the state of pc
fax
i like that see we got a two dollar
super chat from spartan ghost
uh rogue boat ryan throw it in the tower
in the bushes
then we got a five dollar
jim ryan is making sure there's no ps6
i'm telling you it's not but you guys
ain't listening
we got a five dollar subtract from atl
this is atl we do several shows a year
it's
remember last year they were supposed to
do hundreds of shows
they did
yeah
they was counting each show that was
broadcast to you through your
playstation tft
so hundreds of people watched it you had
a hundred shows
got a two dollar super chat from flame
wait i went on early lunch for that yeah
you did you're wasting time
man you wasted your time i hope you
i hope you didn't just sit there and
watch and i hope you ate while you
watched he lost his appetite
he said my stomach hurt he said i don't
feel so good
i got a tummy ache like he ain't too
much candy
it was nothing sweet there buddy that
wasn't bad
hey listen i'm not typically negative as
you all know i'm mr positive over here
right
dab was
that was ass i'm sorry pardon me pardon
me from a language that was bad that was
if we had to write this out of uh out of
ten what do y'all rate this
yeah i'm writing the buck cheeks out of
ten i really yeah
how many butt cheeks out of ten you give
it booty i'm giving it a 10 out of 10 on
butt cheeks man yeah that that thing is
crazy boy that was it
like
i was expecting like a final fantasy 16
thing
wasn't there a leaked post saying that
like final fantasy 16 was gonna be at
this like yo this has been my best yeah
yet this year
this year son i'm barry bonds in this
joint
on on on the uh
shout out to shout out to atl shout out
to mick fury i'm looking at some of
y'all the scores in the chat i see a
zero out of ten i see a negative hundred
good lord oh wait i see a cat i see a
dog emoji with the poop emoji you got
side y'all
it's gonna be okay i'm i'm stirring the
cauldron up oh my god
we'll follow the playstation fanboy
tears in that cauldron oh man
bubbles playstation system is in some
trouble
i can't really be on twitter like that
at work no more did they say that this
was going to be like a mainly like
independent show because if they did
then i got to rescind some of the
slander if they did
i don't know what they said there's
i told them grab their expectations and
put it in the chocolate and put it to
sleep
he put that joint in a deep chokehold
punch
it was bad
y'all let me know somebody in the chat
please let me know if um if they
announced like the temper your
expectations y'all gotta know that aaron
greenberg tweet that those notes and now
somebody let me know playstation people
never say temporary expectations oh man
but they let these dudes run crazy
that's why when they run into the brick
wall if you paint it like a uh like a
tunnel
coyote that's what we're doing like he's
first i'ma be real with you i did not
expect it to be that bad like
and that's short i don't know it's gonna
be that short either so
that's another thing i thought it was
gonna be worse
how much worse could that get i thought
they was coming with blood born for the
pc oh now
you know what it would have saved it
though
it would have blew this show straight
off the map
you would have seen playstation flying
off the road right now they clipping
their wings and taking their wings off
their playstation you got a bunch of
playstation 5's naked inside the living
room right now with the why me face
my joy ain't getting no burn like the
last game i played on my ps5 was uh
uncharted 3. for the record i'm halfway
through that that's the last like oh
that this is this is pretty bad blowing
into that controller still won't save
this show i'm trying i'm trying to i'm
trying to see if the game will pop out
oh no
[Music]
it's not a genie king um
he took the day off when it come to the
reactions man and after watching this oh
i wish i would have took the day off
i don't blame them i don't blame them
king said now well i got to bring these
jokes because i know a lot of these
playstation dudes are sad right now so
hey let me lift your spirits
i want to say this yo it was people in
the actual playstation chat
you know going in on that joint man like
this this was bad sadly but if they
know what it is but you know what makes
it absolute worse let me let me tell you
what really makes it worse and this is
all serious and it's no cap okay there
is no game pass for you
every game you sorted you got to pay for
so they're asking you they took your
time now they want to take your money on
booboo like butt cheeks like this is not
cool right now if you had a game pass
situation you understand
i'm done
[Laughter]
tweeted the playstation tweet and it
said that's it for the episode of state
of play what was your favorite reveal
peachy quote
y'all can watch the show different let's
open super chats real quick we got to
find out super chat from uh
um
how did you guys pronounce that his name
again
hargie cheney at least when xbox shows
you a bunch of indie games a bunch of
them will come to game pass what was
that sony uh king was just talking about
that you guys you guys just you got guys
had that same brain leak man are we sure
that's not king are we sure that's not
keep you on your phone king is that not
you i'm joking i'm joking well you know
no no my boy texted me he got kicked
over so oh i hate to hear that we got to
find out super chat from bunty halo was
getting too much attention they had to
do something but that wasn't it
no well you know what bunty let me tell
you something that is true they knew
that halo stuff was coming out and they
expected it not to hit as much as it did
and let me tell you something you can't
you can't run from that you can run from
it all you like but it's inevitable and
they didn't need it last year and they
needed this year going into this holiday
where the competition has absolutely
nothing and what you've seen is
you know indies are not going to save
these dudes this time they're going to
have to come swinging king let me count
this let me counter that oh no go at it
go ahead go just to clarify king
get a little bit of exclusive
is your topic this week to stay the
point
no no no i'm not i'm not going to beat a
dead horse
or a swollen pegasus
[Laughter]
but shout out to shout out to bg and big
cloud and a few of the ones keeping the
rail on the timeline right now because
they got other options to play their
games you understand these dudes got pcs
they have switches they have stuff like
this
we're looking this we're looking at this
through the eyes of the playstation dude
who bet his farm on the place
you bet your farm on the playstation and
now you said okay this holiday season
when i take off because i'm gonna take
off at the end of the year i'm gonna
play these games black friday i'm gonna
buy my games i'm going in because you
know they got to wait for deals so you
know the deals come up and black friday
you buy one get one free and you're
going inside or you buy one get one half
off and you like what what am i gonna
purchase what i'm gonna play and they
just showed you state of play was state
of delay state of weight state of butt
cheeks this is not it this is not it go
back to this y'all go
just out of character hold up hold up
hold up
curiosity out of curiosity cognito are
you still in that chat if you're in that
chat type in there if you thought this
was hard or not is it is that fake
cognito or real cognitive no he he was
under the iop account
okay
he went back to bed after yeah
two games look good the king of fighting
is a third party game the king of
fighters you don't look good to me you
know i'm just like fighting games
i mean you know hey look i'm with it i'm
showing it every time um we don't need
that don't show it every week you
showing up try to save yourself i'm with
it and i'm hopping in that beta i'm
gonna get my hori fights together can we
be like a little bit serious too with
whatever i see what like to me
how did playstation look at this state
of play it said publish that you know
what to say like
i want to i want to respond to that i
want because i was going to because
kanga kind of said that earlier um it's
one of those situations that we're like
all right y'all know xbox we're going to
run it with forza and know the front of
running with halo and everything that's
coming up this holiday season it was
like it's one of those like uh not rough
wiggling but it's the simpsons mean it's
like stopping he's already dead they
already know if they don't got nothing
dropping outside of what third party
which is call of duty and battlefield on
ps5
i wouldn't but i wouldn't drop this
though i wouldn't i wouldn't have jumped
out there but i wouldn't have dropped
this though this is something that you
got to drop
this this october was still though
okay so
oh let me tell you why i would have
dropped it oh right why
i would have dropped it because one the
playstation fives is selling
okay
regardless to what playstation fives are
selling you can't get them in stores you
got people
thoroughly bamboozled so they drink in
the cooler they can actually see how bad
the the building is burning down but
they still want that penthouse apartment
and they still running inside cooking up
all right so he's still looking at that
situation not knowing it's not the wave
but again it's still selling right so
you got to give the fan base something
because a lot of noise is coming from
one end of the room so what do they have
they have a bunch of indie games and
they want to highlight a bunch of indie
stuff star ocean was the big ticket item
um
not for nothing star ocean is the one
that i'm purchasing
now that's that's no cap there's no bs
that's no
100 i saw a star ocean even though i
don't like the bon jovi haircut but
i know where it's about
excuse me i know it's about that retro
style that feel i hope the music kicks
in i hope it's a hard core uh japanese
theme in it you know um because star
ocean is definitely lit in that manner
it might it reminded me of fantasy star
online that filled with a little open
world of monster hunter so i want that
that feel with that game
that and for everybody that certain
stuff reached and i think the big ticket
item brought them to the show
and everybody saw little stuff like bug
snacks or something like that maybe you
did try buck snacks you want that dlc
maybe you did like certain things so
maybe that amtrak simulator did hit home
for people you know um but there's stuff
there for each and everybody but the big
ticket item was star ocean that nobody
was talking about and that now got a
chance to talk about it so star ocean
did look good to me it did look like it
had promise to it like he was bouncing
through the world flying through the
world it looked really good for me so
if i take anything away from me they got
70
out of that show for me
hey um
shout out to barrett j y'all make sure
y'all go subscribe to level one
lv1gaming.com y'all y'all make sure
y'all subscribe to the youtube channel
as well
um super chat super chat should have
been a tweet indeed kind sir sure that
should have been in the blog post um
let's see
garunda oh i'm killing his name and i'm
garuda okay garuda intruder that state
of play got hit by
[Music]
that state of play got hit by a crystal
d my family isn't enough oh [ __ ] hustle
what are you talking come on y'all it's
it was bad though it it's halley was bad
man and it wasn't that bad when you
start when you step back from it right
you step back step back and i want to go
to bed you got to look at the pitcher in
his entirety right look at it
in his hole
they have an rpg i know
it's going to have upwards of 50 hours
there it's going to have upwards of 50
hours and it continues that star ocean
story for anybody that's a hardcore
playstation dude that's been there
that's been capping for these dudes for
a minute i mean real old school dudes uh
you got the the 30s and above in there
you know and then you got the new dudes
that don't know about star ocean that's
going to look over and be like yo that's
kind of lit so
just check it out
i'm telling i would recommend it without
even playing it i'll recommend it oh
i'll tell you to go play the old ones
and once you play the old ones you're
definitely going to buy the new one
you're definitely going to buy the new
one go check that out
look at the end of the day we got to
find out super chat from faso 7. i want
the utang uh clan game with
man you guys are starting to just do
stuff to annoy like to have me
mispronounce stuff at this point
as a dark character now man like they'd
be putting some crazy stuff in this
jazzer so i we're solved solve gotta be
great now i'm sitting here dying
i want that wu-tang clan game with rock
him and tragedy is that gaddafi i
believe yeah
yeah oh um
outlaws right yeah okay all right i'll
see if it come back and come back a
little slowly but i'm getting it um
shout out to rock him changing the game
as as we know it um king it's you know
everybody was doing the one thing and he
he literally made people wrap around him
and he started the whole like liverpool
like straight bar
after watching that verses that just
went over krs one and big daddy kane
um
early on in in that fight with rock kim
versus kane you know i was pure rock him
100
big daddy kane hats off to you sir
salute you 100 percent black don't crack
for real you definitely ain't break bend
or fold tray way all way with you
um
this dude
100 personified exactly what hip hop was
from the 80s
and up
this
man gave 100 in that versus and
i mean his bangers i thought chaos one
was gonna go there and molly whopper
and chaos one got slaughtered
yeah like
on holiday yeah yeah i heard it didn't
turn out too well but you know i'm such
a fan of the game in the end before my
time
that's the game man and they both know
how to rock a crowd
after all these years so i'm explaining
to my wife right she's watching it and
she's not understanding exactly what's
going on with the verses i said listen
listen there's two ways of interacting
with the crowd chaos one is going to
interact with the crowd with having you
singing his lyrics back and forth and
going inside you know the crowd
cain is going to bring that hype and
that showmanship and he's used to his
dances and stuff like that so when you
saw him bring out dances and they
started doing bugging and breaking this
is all hip-hop 100 that felt so new york
it was crazy it was 40 and above only
don't come in here it wasn't 40 and
above
you know if you ain't have no gray in
your bed get up out of here
oh man pull your pants up put on the
belt no sagging alive it was kind of
crazy but
back to this state of play which
you understand
this is exactly how the state of play
felt it made you lose your train of
thought made you go on to other things
and made you focus on different things
because it wasn't nothing of true
substance other than the big ticket item
that was there now i understand on paper
if you write that stuff down on paper
and you say start we're gonna uh
create a show around star ocean
and push that out you saw a new ip i
think that was a multiplayer uh type of
game uh in the beginning that death game
um you had death note which is some
dude's game of the year which is in
there so okay so you have real uh a
multiplayer game that they need and
y'all you're gonna not act like they
don't need that because they need that
uh you have that rpg the big ticket item
you have death note which is for some
people game of the year that people are
waiting for to come to that platform
that they could buy then you also had uh
the the amtrak sim the cart racing game
if anybody was looking for a new car
racer that probably will come in at a uh
at a nice price of 40.39.95
boom you got it right there and if you
are five nights at freddy's fans and
there's tons of you people that are five
nights at freddy's fans that joint
looked intriguing it looked fun and
there's another chapter in a line that
you enjoy so if you're looking at it on
paper i'm not saying that the execution
was perfect but the on paper was
definitely something that put out i
don't agree that it should be the blog
post i think they they needed this right
now because there's too much information
heading in one area you need to bring
some of that information back this way
and for a lot of people to cap and say
oh i didn't like bug snacks i know a lot
of people that played that game and they
might want some dlc for it so again it
was a solid show was it the show that
everybody wanted no and was it a show to
go up against a halo single event this
is the difference when you have a aaa
banger type of a title that you could
put out that one game to
to just you know drive uh uh
thought and grab media attention
these games are little or uh lesser
games double a uh some single leg games
and this game these games actually uh
come out and you you get a chance to uh
partake in them i wish and and i'm gonna
keep saying it until it happens i wish
they take playstation now serious i wish
they'd take the playstation uh uh
consumer serious i wish they start to
respect your money because
you guys would have walked away with
this show at 10 foot 10 if all the stuff
was in playstation now day and date
if you saw that the way you would have
watched the show is completely different
now and oh i'm going to play this on
this day now you're scheduling play
dates for yourself and time that you're
going to have off
you can't do that now this is why this
this show didn't hit hartford because
you're looking for bangers and when you
do that you're taking a segment of your
consumer base and you're placing them on
the sidelines because now you're looking
with discerning eyes of finances and not
enjoyment you understand so i i think
that's where they fail to connect with
the consumer please they have to hear
you guys cry you have to speak out don't
listen to these fake generals telling
you you need money to support developers
developers are getting paid
get them into a service that keeps you
engagement high change the metrics stop
worrying about sales and start worrying
about how y'all play your games because
if people are telling you that you're
playing twitter more than you're playing
this then it's a problem
i mean i'll say though i don't know the
name of that card racing game that game
looks fun to me so like i said i kind of
wish playstation would have put their
own like ip mascots in that game in
place of these ones that we don't know i
think that was the third party
yeah it's called a cart racer drift oh
[ __ ] third party yeah i don't think that
was this
well i'm just i mean i just assumed it
was first party maybe i shouldn't assume
that it's first party but yeah i mean
any and even if it is third party they
should implement like a special
playstation character anyway but i don't
know the car races always look fun to me
so uh i'll be i'll check that one out
just to see how it controls
that store i can actually play down on
game pass right king
well i don't know if it's on game pass
at this moment but i know
it's not all right it's going to be
coming to game pass at some point it
probably come out on game pass the day
it comes out for the playstation
that'd be crazy if it did because yeah
you know that's something stuff that i
know my man phil dominus maximus are
really expensive do do um so and i want
jim ryan to get up on his petty he needs
to start
matching
and changing the metrics he needs to
start matching that energy
okay so this car race the game is on
xbox already shout out to uh nico in the
chat i appreciate it oh man nico you
just done gave me too much ammo
drift apparently that's something yeah
it's sweet so man why you did that to me
nico why you see me trying to be nice
nico
nico why you put that battery in my back
now it's time for me to explode
honey
king of fighters you know i know king of
fighters they won't do this with the
game um king you remember back uh kof
like 97 98 remember that art style yeah
they won't go back to that because it's
a little too much hand drawn up
animation they won't go back to that but
i would love to i would just like love
to see that same thing with like marvel
versus capcom too they're supposed to
this digital eclipse is supposed to
remake that um they're in talks with
disney right now um free marvel vs
capcom too if y'all don't know the
hashtag get familiar please
they won't go back to the og version of
marvel races capcom 2 but i don't think
that they will because this that was
like everything was like hand drawn
everything was like they're not doing
that um who's the people
that make guilty gear
um ooh
the ark arc something
systems i do believe
i believe so
um you will have to look to them
to to
artists that never left the 2d sprite
realm
you know um
those those artists that hand drawn art
that was the pinnacle for us because we
was counting frames of animation
we was actually looking at frames
now
when when you're into the digital 3d
space
it changes the hit detection it changes
how the game plays um
and and you can see that when it comes
from um
stuff like uh uh uh what is that uh for
neogeo um
samurai showdown when they went from 2d
to 3d
um
you can tell the difference in the speed
the head detection uh stuff like that
the only successful
3d fighter that i think that nailed it
out of the gate because there was no
comparison to it was uh um tekken
you know
you don't consider virtual fighter um
the closest comparison than that i think
virtual fighter by default as a 3d
fighter was the best one that did
it remember it was on a 2d plane
so you didn't go into 3d at all it
actually emulated the thought of 3d it
was just made out of polygons oh god
second remember tekken you was able to
dip in
3d yeah right so
and tekken did that one arm
you know left arm
right arm left leg right leg type of
thing that gave you a little bit more
control over it whereas retro fighters
had the punch kick block button you know
um so
it's different iterations on it by
default the the godfather is virtual
fighters but in that 3d space i think
you know um
tekken took it it was a game a
little-known game from sony uh called
tobol
made by square enix well square
uh
uh 60 frames per second uh
polygon flat shaded polygons
the most entertaining playstation
fighter that i played when it came out
and then toble 2 really took it to the
next level it was from the maker of the
dragon ball z to art designer uh from
dragon ball z beautiful game it's stuff
like that that actually
has me as a fan of playstation from
the genesis of the playstation no pun
intended um
this stuff here is going to be stuff
here for these people for this day to
play that resonates with them
it's not a total loss dudes i may joke
and i may laugh around but i'ma tell you
this i'm buying star ocean so
um i walked away from that with that if
they had a service where i can partake
it's more games that i saw that i was
interested in but i'm not giving them 60
70 bucks i'm not giving them 40 bucks
for no car racing game i'm not doing
none of that stuff if i'm i'm a
discerning uh purchaser um my money will
be used in a manner that i choose and
like i said i will only give them for
that star ocean the bon jovi haircut got
me i mean did you see anything that you
would purchase in there at any point in
time
attic it's not me
is muted um what about you hustle
yeah um the very last game i call it
like thomas the tank engine i saw them
little jokes flying on twitter the first
game that they or the last game that
they showed on that independent game i
did i like to look at that king of
fighters but i'm not going to really
include access third party that's right
more like this third party anyway
um
and the car race the game for me um i
don't think that i saw anything else
that i was particularly like interested
in i'm not the game in the beginning the
death game the um multiplayer game
you know as far as multiplayer and
playstation
i'm keeping trouble with you they're
going to need more than that they're
going to need way more than that to
compete with what's going on on the
other side
you build a house with one brick you
know you start off with one brick okay
but they gonna need you know about a
thousand them but i mean a little bricks
i'm just saying i'm just saying like
look
i'm not gonna sit up here and totally
slam to that game it looks cool but i
don't really think that that's something
that i'm particularly interested in i'll
try it for the sake of trying it and i
don't want to go in with like a negative
mindset on it right um because you never
know i might like it i definitely might
like it but
yeah it just just joined the show in
particular like i said the only game i
wanted to buy was the last one that they
showed that was the first one that i
remember seeing at the future of gaming
that was like one of those games one of
those indie games and i like i like the
way that the art style is we saw a
little bit more and that the name of
that game still escapes my mind it still
scares my mind however that one looks
like the most especially out of this
showcase uh the five nights at freddy's
joining us i know you king i know you
said
i think i'll try that i think i'll try
that game man y'all got it i'm good
uh that that's a big pass i'm sure
someone in this chat will get me to play
that damn game
yeah uh
anything that you saw out of the attic
before we wrap this up
five nights at freddy
that's all
wow
i don't care about the fighter all right
star ocean he really hit me like that
um i literally watched this because i i
really thought final fantasy 16 was
gonna be there
so um i'm disappointed
it's it's it's a it's a it's a zero out
of ten to me
oh my god there was literally another
seven five nights at freddy's so it got
to be a one you gotta be yeah
nah five nights at freddy ain't even
gonna raise that bar whatsoever five
nights at freddy's something i play if
it's in game pass like ain't really
it ain't really something that i would
ever buy
well out of out of a 10 um i give the
show uh uh uh a four
um
you know um interest
two for the game that i would purchase
and two games that was interesting to me
and those are maybe purchases so they
get a point each uh but definite per
anyway i'm gonna bump it up i'll give it
a five uh three three points for the
game i would purchase because i think
star ocean was a huge surprise for me
yeah it's
it just it it didn't do anything for me
at all like to be honest with you i i i
people that like the head fighter stuff
i'm sure you got something with the king
of fighters
that didn't do nothing for me people
that like to start i'm hoping that gave
you something that didn't do nothing for
me i was really
hoping
that that final fantasy 10
i mean 15 was on lock
uh but you know what it wasn't there i
mean 16. it wasn't there
so i mean it is what it is
we pretty much just did this at this
point for the chat i hope we made the
show better than it was to you guys
because it was pretty bad
so you know
it is what it is but you guys got
anything else to say before we wrap this
up
nope bye
[Laughter]
you got anything you got anything to
tell them uh hustle you got anything
going on
uh
nothing going on at the moment um i will
be doing a documentary on bang bang bang
bang hold on
one
number two you probably can't see it but
um
yeah yeah nba streets volume two um at
some point hopefully top of the year um
i'll be working on that you can catch me
every tuesday on the attic show sorry i
wasn't there yesterday had some great
stuff we had some family stuff um
well this was fun to giggle with y'all
um i had fun doing this but um yeah
playstation
yeah you know
come a little better next time post just
do a little better
be all right
oh well we had a super chat yes we do
heart geeks your knee
hard geek shiny with the five dollar
super chat hmm
halo game play uh play trailer sony
state of play yeah halo hands down i
have to agree with you man
this uh
this is definitely
it was bad man it was bad but we're
going we're going to uh let you guys in
on this man uh keep in mind tomorrow at
5 p.m i will be streaming uh so
definitely uh look into that
you know we're we'll be seeing you iop
this sunday
at 11 00 a.m unfortunately got my topic
yet we we we do have a we do have a good
guess for you guys i'm not going to
spoil that and let cognito tweet that
out but yeah definitely tune in for that
and until this sunday or until the next
reaction whatever
playstation decides to do this um we're
gonna try to stream a little bit more of
these state of plays even though how bad
it was it's still entertaining for you
guys it wasn't i got you guys here
but um we'll talk to you guys later and
i appreciate everyone for coming through
my topic might be halo man
hey sony
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you